audi is reaching for a bigger slice of
the luxury pie with its brand new
second-generation r8 supercar built on
the bones of the Lamborghini Huracan and
this is the fastest most powerful and
most expensive car audi has ever built
we wanted to go with an evolution of a
successful design and I think our
designers did a great job on it the top
spec v10 plus version that we test it
puts out 610 horsepower with a naturally
aspirated 5.2 liter lump the car puts
power to all four wheels with a 7-speed
dual-clutch transmission and it does 0
to 60 in just about 3 seconds if those
specs sounds familiar because the her
akan built by Volkswagen stablemate
Lamborghini uses the exact same
powertrain probably the biggest
challenge to keep those two brands
separate
but Audi wins races the new r8 contains
fifty percent of the same parts used on
the LMS race car that won the rolex 24
Hours of Daytona earlier this year to
race a car that's almost exactly like
this is really unique and special first
time here at Daytona to win the 24 Hours
of Daytona really speaks tremendously to
what this car can do
driving the car at the Daytona
International Speedway the lighter
weight and the rear wing are welcome
changes I've it in performance mode with
manual shifting of course oh you feel
the car flipping already
I've never driven this fast in my life
I'm actually just quiet we were maxing
out the g-meter doing about 180 miles
now around the bank corners here at
Daytona it is a feeling unlike anything
else I've ever experienced except for
maybe being on a roller coaster but
standing in line for a roller coaster
isn't nearly as luxurious as the cockpit
of an r8 v10 plus starting at a hundred
ninety thousand dollars it feels like a
bargain
No